so far you learned about phylogenetic
tree and its development
next let's understand how we can apply
it to a real life problem and address
biological question
let's take an example of covert 19
pandemic
whenever a pandemic outbreak happens
there are several questions that needs
to be answered these questions can be
any of the following
where did this novel karna virus come
from
which animal what location
and how did it start infecting humans to
understand and design the vaccine
against any virus we need to address
these questions
in this objective our goal is to
understand its zoonotic origin that is
from which animal it has been originated
to address this question we will have to
find data patterns in the available
genomes of coronavirus that can help
answer this question phylogenetic
analysis approach can help us to
understand the origin of the normal
source code too
to do so we aimed to perform
phylogenetic comparison or analysis
between the sarscope two genome
sequences with sequences of other corner
virus strains from other animals
as this pandemic originated in china
therefore in our objective be focused on
china as a geological location and want
to compare strains from human sarscope
to bad coronary virus and pangolins
to understand the zoonotic origin we
will search ncbi virus
we will search for coronaviridae as
shown here
next we are applying specific filters to
select the sequences
select china as a geographical region
as we know covert 19 was initiated in
china
next complete as a nucleotide
completeness to eliminate any partial
sequences
then humans bat and pangolins as host
for corn coronavirus infection
we have now downloaded or obtained let's
say three sequences from four different
organisms or species origin
that is human sars cov2 paths our scope
2 pat corona virus and pangolin
coronavirus
we have downloaded sequences in four
independent groups
as mentioned besides we have also
downloaded the reference genome for sas
cove 2 both as a faster sequence file as
well as a genbank file
genbank file will be used for codon
translation during phylogenetic analysis
so here as mentioned we have in
geosequences for five samples
from each of the pangolin coronavirus
pat coronavirus sarskoff to mers and
sars
once we have sequences next we can
perform phylogenetic analysis using the
phylogenetic tree module on the tpi info
platform
so now let's get to tbioinfo
server
here you need to select the ngs data
type as faster
upload the files that is faster
sequences
make groups using the group selection
option and drag the files into groups
here we have made four groups
one each for human sars cove two bad sar
scope bad coronavirus and pangolin
coronavirus
to get a translation coding frame upload
the reference genomic genbank file
format to generate the translation codes
frame
it is needed as we wish to analyze
mutations or changes occurring at amino
acid level
genbank file comprises information about
the sequences coding regions
to get the out groups we are going to
skip this option
if you are willing to understand the
evolutionary time points of origin then
you can proceed with it
now let's create the pipe and graph for
phylogenetic analysis
here we will use the default parameters
for each step
by clicking start we will start building
the pipeline
next perform multiple sequence alignment
by clicking the multiple sequence
alignment option
then click on multiple sequence
alignment amino acids
that translates the msa alignment of
nucleotide sequences
into msa alignments of codons and the
codon matching amino acids
this is done by acquiring a genbank file
select a codon position
for the multiple sequence alignment
here we are not choosing any specific
position we are considering only default
positions
next to generate a phylogenetic tree we
are selecting the all phylogeny methods
option
with the nucleotides at sequence type
parameter
this will automatically execute all the
methods that include ape beast quilts
and constant size b speciation mule
process and b speciation birth death
process
post processing using the tree space
option
the tree space module generates a median
tree from the multiple tree
this is performed in two steps
first the algorithm performs pairwise
distance calculation between trees and
then it constructs the median tree for
which the sum of distances to all other
trees of the set is minimal
now click on the end
to complete the thyrogenic analysis
give a name to your pipeline
and click on
run on cluster
you will be able to view your outputs in
a while
after completing the pipeline we have
obtained various outputs under the
download pipeline output files option
median tree plot dot pdf and median
phonogenetic three dot tre represents
the median phylogenetic tree and all
alltree'splot.pdf represents the four
trees that were generated by each of the
four methods
the all input data
msa out
faster.fa and all input data msa out
faster dot f a dot cluster
represents the multiple sequence
alignment
full table dot tsv represents the
mutation
phyllo trajectory in the median
phytogenetic tree dot tre file can be
visualized in the fig tree
multiple sequence alignment present all
input data msa out faster.fa
file can be visualized using multiple
softwares like qg
to learn more about the exact biological
interpretation of all the outputs that
are obtained here you can refer to
lesson number six phylogenetic analysis
on omex logic learn portal under the
genomics course
and if you face any errors then you can
anytime reach out to us at marketing at
the rate omixlogic.com and we'll be
happy to assist you